hot breath how do you tap into that
authenticity
i mean let's think about who are you
what makes you happy what makes you sad
what
what is your trauma from childhood do
you have any
um what is the thing that gives you
anxiety do you get anxiety
what is your quirk what is the thing
like eminem yourself
like from eight mile where he comes into
the battle
and he just disses himself
before the other guy can he's like yeah
i'm this i'm poor i'm this all these
things
and what's that guy gonna say you don't
have anything to say now you just
clowned yourself
so it's like think about what are all
the things about you that
self-deprecating
not in a way where it's like everybody
is like oh bummered should we give this
guy some antidepressant pills like he
really needs some help like
not necessarily in that way but finding
the joy
in making fun of yourself before someone
else can
like let me just be vulnerable and
authentic like i'm bow legged
that's not real sexy like i'm insecure
about my bow legs like when i put my
feet together look they do this
and then i show everybody like so if
somebody's in the audience looking like
oh she's super bowlegged and then i go
you guys i'm bowling
like look what happens with my legs like
i look like a camel
and like all these things and it's like
oh my god she does look like a camel
and whatever it is it's like i'm being
authentic to
who i am because i actually am insecure
about my bow legs like if i wasn't
insecure about it didn't care then i
won't pretend to be insecure about it
but i actually am so let me just be
honest about that
i'm insecure that i don't speak i'm
embarrassed that i don't speak spanish
everybody stop looking at me i'm
embarrassed
like that i've done that on stage before
because that's my actual feelings like
i'm embarrassed that i don't speak
spanish and everybody's looking at me
and they're judging me stop
judging me everybody and that's just
being authentic that's
just being what i actually think can
feel yeah that's what ron functions told
us on here
was he really found a breakthrough when
he started talking about
what embarrassed him that's good
yeah so just being willing to tap into
that
i guess it gets easier the more you do
it i would imagine but it's first
setting the intention to write about
embarrassing things
that's good that's a good note for even
me writing more material like
what embarrasses me